[Music]
hello dear friends and thank you for
joining us here on their program I'd
like to know it is always a blessing and
a privilege for us to come to you
through this program that allows us to
connect connect with you to interact
with your questions and answer and and
inquiries rather answering them from the
Bible and the spirit prophecy it is a
privilege to have Pastor C with me
Pastor what a blessing to have you here
in the program always be good to be here
and always good to study the word of God
praise the Lord for that and we want to
encourage you to not forget to send your
questions to the following uh address
which is found uh at TVM tv.org that's
tvtv do.org
we are delighted that you are contining
to send your questions and we also enjoy
the opportunity that they give us to
study to do some research and to learn
and study God's word Pastor C if you can
uh please lead us into prayer and we'll
go into the questions all righty
gracious father how we praise you and
thank you for the privilege of studying
your word that you've written this word
that it can be studied and understood
and that when we study with the
intention of putting into practice that
which we know to be right you will give
us the understanding that we need amen
and help us by your grace and your
abiding strength to do those things
because we know that righteousness is
right doing so help us Lord to study to
do to be drawn closer to you each day
and we thank you precious father in
Jesus name amen amen so Pastor CA we
have this question the first question
that comes to us is from Heather in
Gisborne new Zealand beautiful country
and I have the privilege to visit New
Zealand and hopefully one day I can go
again and see this beautiful part of the
world yes um now the question that
Heather has is the following it says
Adam or Adam is the image and likeness
of God image and likeness means
reflection like in a mirror if it is
true that Adam is the image and likeness
of God then the reverse must be true
that God is the image and likeness of
Adam but this doesn't sound right to me
please explain regards Heather so Pastor
what can we say about this question that
Heather has it's a good question it's a
good question it it assumes a lot uh and
and and hello New Zealand I've also had
the privilege as has Pastor David uh of
of visiting New Zealand and preaching
there uh fine people um just in a
beautiful country yes um
a couple quotes quickly from the uh book
Patriarchs and
Prophets because the question does
assume some things that are not
necessarily so yes man was born says
Ellen White to
Bear God's image both in outward
appearance and
character but this line I think is
important Christ Alone is the express
image of the father mhm but man was
formed in the likeness of God so it may
be a little bit of a stretch Pastor
David for us to assume that image and
likeness when dealing with God and man
means reflection in a mirror because
even at our best we imperfectly says
Elon white reflect the image of God that
is that's a spiritual statement but I I
believe it is also a physical statement
yeah um because first of all God isn't
shed in light yes and and we don't know
precisely what what what he looks like
um so it may be a little much to assume
that we are expressly looking like God
when she says only Christ has that
privilege pastor and you are right on
the money with this actually because the
the important part in the creation when
we go to go back to Genesis you know one
uh where he speaks when God speaks to
Crea men and I would like to just go to
the verse 26 Genesis 126 it says there
and God said let us make men in our
image after our likeness and let them
have dominion over the fish of the sea
and over the foul of the air and over
the cattle and over all the Earth and
over and over every creeping thing that
creep it on upon the Earth so then verse
27 so God created men in his own
image in the image of God created he him
male and female created he them so when
we notice here the Bible says that God
in plural L us he's mentioning so
there's not just you know one of the
beings but is God the Father God the Son
and the Holy Spirit all of them are
working in the creation of man they
decide to make men in the likeness that
is the the in the image in the likeness
that is speaking of a a resemblance in
the appearance so in other words God has
sort of a body like ours in the sense of
like a head
you know arms a body that kind of thing
it's not like we are made out of you
know out of something that's completely
different it's it's very in that sense
is similar but it's as just a
resemblance and the image and the
likeness is dealing as mentioned clearly
in regards to character and outward
appearance but the only one that is
actually a mirror like if you will like
she you know like our friend hea
mentions one that the reverse is true
God is you know the same with the other
individual is Jesus who in Hebrews
chapter 1:3 mentions there the Bible
that he is the express image of the
father yes so in the sense that they are
equal they are both the same that they
are you know like looking at a mirror if
you will you know they're they're
basically the same there's nothing
there's nothing that about the the of
the father that is superior to Christ
because Christ was as the father is God
and only in roles is where the Lord
Jesus submits to the father as the son
in in the in the sense of he he
volunteer submits the father as a son um
with that said the you know the expl the
explanation here or the answer to our
friend Heather I believe is is correct
that Jesus is the only that is one that
is like the father Express image of God
we are just created in likeness in this
in a similar fashion as far as outwardly
but we are not uh God is not a
reflection of who we are you know I
don't know if every time it uses God in
the early chapters of Genesis it it uses
Elohim I expect most of the times it do
Elohim of course is a plural word the I
am ending is equal to the s in the in
the uh in our mod our language today it
is interesting that the the Hebrew mind
the semetic mind never really really
challenged itself with worrying about
what God looked like you know it's it's
a western concept to try to Facebook God
you um you know if you look at all of
the the names for God and there are
about 60 you know um from El Shai to uh
Jehovah nii Jehovah Rafa Jehovah they're
all they're all verb names what they
were interested in not what God looks
like but what God does for me that's
that's what the Bible concentrate
concentrates on the fact that God loves
me and that love uh it determines how he
acts towards me his salvific acts in my
life so they never really concerned
themselves that much with how what he
looked like did he have a nose did he
have eye did he have hair did he have
was he bald did he have long hair you
know I don't care about that what I'm
concerned about is when I go to God I
find a loving Creator and and savior who
is concerned about me who is willing to
hear uh my prayers and answer and who
has put himself on the line for me and
that was enough for me I will see God in
heaven as much as he allows me to see
when I when I get there yes uh but for
now I'm much more concerned that he
loves me and that when I call he is
there to answer um and and and I'm not I
don't want to say I'm I'm I use this
term dogging this request because it is
legit but the Bible does not concern
itself that much with what God is in
physical appearance or if we match him
in physical appearance Ellen White lets
us know that we we were like God in
character we were pure unsullied moral
in character pure in our thoughts we we
resembled God in that at the beginning
at the beginning correct not now we're
trying to but at at the beginning and
and that was enough and that's what the
Bible addresses to itself to in those
early chapters and you know it's it's
good point Pastor you mentioned you know
the the fact that we were created in the
image of God being innocent without you
know propensity to sin we were not
created you know with idea even to
experiment death yes this is why even
after sin death it's a foreign concept
to to us you know no matter how much you
want to raliz and want to say you know
I'm going to die nobody wants to die yes
we were not made for that so uh and
obviously because of same the
degeneration of their human race has
been so severe that we are just a shadow
of how we were created in the original
you know what Adam was made Adam was
much more beautiful I mean tall and and
he resembl closer to what God would have
been and so for us today to think that
God looks like
me it it would be a mistake you know we
have to realize that we don't look like
the Lord want us it's the Gen the
generation of sin that has made us you
know like who we are now with full of
infirmities uh you know not you know not
not even symmetrical right sometimes you
know one of us are good you know we have
a lot of issues physically and stuff so
that's is why we need need to remember
like you mentioned we're not to really
think too much of how God is you know
specifically because the fact is that he
is perfect created in all things and and
he once we get to see him and once we
see the Lord coming we will be just
delighted to be able to be his presence
be will be transformed a twinkle in the
eye amen this corrupted will put on
incorruptibility so it's important that
you know we keep that in mind yeah I I I
think it's it's it's it's it's crucial
to remember that we we want to be like
God
we as we've gotten as we've come down to
to human we've gotten worse and worse
and worse and worse we don't even look
like Adam did you know we're not in the
image of Adam anymore CU we've we've
we've sin has done so many so many so
much to us and so many things have
happened to us uh but one day it's all
going to be changed and we're going to
we're going to look like him in
character uh and physical stature going
to be a lot bigger and a lot better than
we are now Lord so Heather thank you uh
from New Zealand and um uh we hope that
we answered your question uh uh from the
word of God Amen all righty let's
continue pastor we have the next
question from leita from
Ethiopia uh we thank leita for writing
us from the beautiful country of
Ethiopia and the question is Shalom dear
pastors I hope you are doing well my
name is Lita and I am a university
student from Ethiopia I am very glad to
have the opportunity to ask you a
question where we very thankful that she
can ask us a question for sure my
question is this most of the time I
receive money from people they give me
the exact amount of money that I request
for example if I want to buy shoes I
tell them the price of the shoes and
they send me that exact amount the money
I receive is specifically for purchasing
those shoes do you think I should pay
tithe on this money or should I ask for
an amount beyond the price of the shoes
in order to cover the tithe thank you so
Pastor what is this uh question you know
what what you think about this question
this is a very good question that uh
student who wants to honor the Lord and
wants to do right and not rob the Lord
wants to know what to do in this regard
yeah u i I just got to say spending so
much time uh in Spanish countries
Spanish wife Spanish friends that ler
could be later oh sorry that's maybe
that's coming from your heritage it
could be lat I don't know but it's a
pretty name yeah and thank you for for
asking it
um
tithe my pastor my friend is a contract
we make with the Lord
MH tithe is to be paid on your
increase if someone sends
you money that's
increase it occurs to me that's the the
textbook definition of what tithe is to
be paid on yeah
um if you need something and they send
you that exact amount of money for me I
would still might pay my tithe on it I I
just you know there are some issues that
are pretty much a product of your
relationship with the Lord um uh I don't
get money often that is earmarked for a
specific thing at a specific price so
it's not a problem that I that I tend to
have but I do have times when people
give me gifts not great sums of money
but and I I try to pay tithe on
everything that that that he gives me uh
and I say God gives me because
everything comes from the Lord right uh
uh that falls in the category of of
increase you know I find it you know
interesting that you mention that Pastor
because if if trying to think myself in
the situation that she's
in uh possibly there is very small
income that she can make uh and maybe
the scenario is where she's receiving
the money because the person that wants
to help her with shoes or clothes or
something of that nature uh is not
living in the country and says you know
what you need some shoes tell me how
much it cost and I'll send the money and
if she has to provide a receipt for
example for the shoes you know where
there's a gift I could see where that
might not be possible for her to
necessarily take the tithe out of the
money if that's required uh and at the
same time though if you are increasing
in anything that you have whether is you
know shoes or clothes or whatever and
that's an increase and you need to find
a way to be able to pay tide of that
increase as you well mentioned so uh I
think that's what the Lord wants you to
do now to ask somebody to send you for
example 10% extra so you can pay tight
of that uh I mean that's a way to do it
in a sense but I I think that the the
the key thing is it's are you
sacrificing something you know of your
increase are you willing to say I want
to put 10% of what I receive
in the Lord returning returning to the
Lord and grow in my dependent and in my
confidence in my trust in the Lord to
provide for my needs so this is what I
will suggest you know if you have to
give an account with receipts of what
you receive as gifts you might have to
justay ask for that money but if there's
another way you can you can make more
money out of the other amount of money
you're making you pay the tithe for that
shoe or for the gift that you receive it
may be a little difficult particularly
if the person has given money doesn't
understand the concept of tithe yeah um
I need $10 and I need you to kick in
another dollar because I need to pay my
tithes but but then at that point
they're paying the tithe for you exactly
you're not paying anything you're not
paying the tithe right and tithe is a
personal cover you make with God so um
leita later uh pretty name you've got to
find a way to to be faithful to the Lord
and that's why I think we're kind of we
we're kind of approaching this softly
we're not being too dogmatic because a
lot of these things are are the product
of growth in the Lord you know when I
was younger in the Lord uh and and just
starting I joined church at age 10 only
ADV in my family so a lot of these
decisions I had to make my parents who
were not Christian well they were a
Christian but they weren't they were
holiday Christians you know uh they
couldn't make these decisions for me so
my growth in Christ informed excuse me
my decisions and so as you grow in the
Lord and learn to trust him some of
these things will become a bit easier to
understand a bit easier to work with as
you test him and prove him and he says
do just that and I will show that I that
I am faithful amen amen well um we have
uh very uh another question and I hope
that this answer was good for uh Lita or
L um you know beautiful name but we have
a question now from Titus this is from
Western Kenya Titus and so the question
he has is this first I appreciate secret
and seal for wonderful work they have
been doing have a bless have been
blessed since started listening in 2022
my question is that should Adventists
cast demons and offer Deliverance
prayers to those possessed by demons oh
this is a good question Pastor you know
can Adventist or Adventist should be
involved in casting out demons doing
exorcism if you will or you know praying
Deliverance prayers to those possessed
by demons yeah a couple of things come
to my mind I don't I don't think it
would do us well to run the streets
looking for demons to cast out um I just
don't but I remember the wunga 7th
Adventist Church in Australia uh in
Sydney I don't remember the date but I
was preaching I was with another
minister with 3abn at the time Danny
Shelton was with me he was providing the
music I was doing the preaching and a
fellow came and brought his
demon-possessed daughter wow uh to us
and said we need you need to cast her
out um and she had several
manifestations that let us know that
that Dad was not kidding this girl was
demon possessed wow uh my wife Irma was
with me at the time uh it was it was
very very scary uh we didn't go looking
for that it was brought to us it is my
belief that Christians ought not back
down from from any challenge to the
reign of Jesus Christ and to the power
of Jesus Christ so we ask the man give
us a minute we're going to go next door
we're going to get prayed we're going to
talk about this and then we'll come back
so we did that and we we we went in the
room with her and she wouldn't let us
touch her she wouldn't let us put our
hands on her and she wouldn't let us get
too near her um so we prayed we prayed
for her and uh we believe at the end of
that night uh the demon was cast out um
that was my first first last and
only situation that that was like that
not something not something that I would
go chasing after but the same is true
that he that is in thee is more he that
is with us is more powerful than he is
with them amen um and so as a Christian
who is prayed up and following Jesus
Christ you should not be afraid of the
devil because you resist the devil he
will flee amen ultimately Christ is more
powerful so is it a sin as the way the
question is asked I don't believe it is
sin uh to do that particularly when it
is thrust upon you it is not something
you went looking for amen Pastor I think
that your experien is is really one to
take heed of and and you know it's
interesting that in the book of well
many places but in Mark you know in the
last chapter of The Book of Mark chapter
16 verse1 15 when the Lord is giving you
know the commission to them it says the
following I'm going to read and he said
unto them go ye into all the world and
preach the gospel to Every Creature he
that believeth and is baptized shall be
saved but he that believeth not shall be
damned and these sign shall follow them
that believe in my name shall they cast
out Devils they shall speak with new
tongues they shall take up serpents and
if they drink any deadly thing it shall
not hurt them they shall lay hands on
the sick and they shall recover so now
this is the commission that the lord
gave his disciples to baptize to preach
and teach to believe in the Lord and to
you know follow his
Commandments now the signs do follow if
you are in the Lord and you are doing
his work not looking for like you said
not trying to advertise yourself as a as
a Healer or as a cast you know somebody
that cast demons but when you you you
face that in your experience and you are
living a life in submission to the Lord
mhm and you're following his his his
word and you're following his
Commandments there is
no there's nothing that in the power of
Christ you cannot overcome yes including
demon possessed individuals and in this
scenario you know if you meet that
individual that person the Lord can help
you but I would be very very careful to
uh try to ask or say that Adventists are
to be offering themselves to C of demons
because that's not the purpose of our
our commission is not to go around
trying to find you know who is demon
poses and you know to be free is as we
preach and teach the gospel as we are
having an encounter with those that are
un believing and those that are trying
to come to the Lord if we meet with
somebody like that God will give us the
power then to deliver that individual
that person from from the grasp of the
demon possession you know the Lord has
promised to give protection to to his
people yes but we don't want to tempt
the Lord you know you don't want to go
around advertising yourself as an
exorcist yes uh first of all the the
pride in that may may cause you to lose
the Holy Spirit but if you get yourself
in hot water God has promised to deliver
you I remember years ago I was the
electrician for our our our camp for
years and years and years and um uh fell
asked me to to to hook up his tent he
had it in a field and so there was a
house nearby he said go in the basement
and just find a power box get up so it's
easy enough thing to do I went in and I
didn't know that I was standing in about
6 Ines of water I didn't know until I I
dropped a screwdriver something and I
heard just spop you know I said oh my
goodness I'm standing in water and I was
getting ready to to you know you got hot
ground I was I I was bringing in 220 so
three wires you know uh and bring it
into a box and break it down to two 110
uh that could have been a bit of a
problem absolutely but I said see the
Lord looked out for me when I wasn't
looking out for myself and that's what
God has promised if you get into a
situation God's going to help you
through but you don't want to just tempt
the Lord and put yourself in the
situations where he's got to to deliver
you and you have to remember the story
you know that of of those of that man
who was demon possessed and these sons
of a Jewish leader went
to tried to deliver him and he said I
know you know Jesus I know Paul but who
are you who the thing is are we in
Christ if we're in Christ the power and
the sign will f follow but if we are not
in Christ and we're looking you know if
we are you know uh with self in our
lives even if even if we have a one
cherish sin we will not have that power
that Victory and we have to be very
mindful that's why I believe that to you
know to face the enemy to face something
like that you have to be really grounded
in Christ yes and truly surrender to him
and he in you so that he can use you for
that uh experience of having victory
over those those you know those U demon
possessed individuals so any other
thoughts Pastor before we finish no I
think we we had it pretty well you
you're the devil's not afraid of us he's
afraid of our boss amen and unless
you're working for that boss there's
nothing about you that he fears amen uh
so you need to be prayed up and you need
to be on the boss's team amen if you're
going to defeat the enemy praise the
Lord praise the lord well our time has
come to an end we thank you once again
for allowing us to go into your homes
and to share this time with you may God
bless you and keep you is our prayer
blessings to you
[Music]